so now you've got your own show and
you've got to prove to the world all of
a sudden that you're the world's
greatest talk show host it's a lot of
pressure yeah it's weird it's just weird
because i don't know how to do it yet
you're doing fine i read a review today
said you were really good you got a
three or four star review in the daily
news they said shows a lot of promise
like i know the first show was insane
first of all i was like my mom and dad
were there my aunt and uncle my uncle
had a cane while he was limping around i
come in for the meeting after the show
and my room has flowers in it and
balloons i thought like i got my
appendix out this is insane i'm hosting
a party i can't i can't they're having
cheese and crackers like having done
like my own show for a while i know when
i have my family around like i remember
my first day at nbc radio was big i was
coming to new york i had worked out of
new york i hadn't been in new york ever
and the entire sales department crowded
into the booth with me to watch me on my
first day and i got laryngitis how to go
home it makes it like they put because
you can be as calm as you want
you're like all right i'm ready let's go
do the monologue and on their way from
my office to the studio for four people
stop and they grab your arm like hey
jimmy you know what i do
i breathe i breathe right breathe just
breathe hit the mark
and then tell the next show and then
they're great and then you walk and then
another guy goes hey jimmy you know what
i do buddy don't be nervous picture
everyone naked right there you go okay
great so when you talk about this new
job being work
the hardest part for you i think is
i mean okay the first night you get to
robert de niro
and you got this one coming up
timberlake
in order to get to make this first week
dynamic you had to call these people
personally yeah and say please do my
show is that not the most embarrassing
horrible aspect of this really yeah
because
i i could never make that i want to do
it but it's like do you mind tina fey
which is oh god she is the coolest girl
ever and i said i said to you and she
goes i'll do anything for you i said
will you do my second show because
that's the way when you say you had to
pick up the phone you have her home
phone number and you called her
personally and do you feel like maybe
she's saying herself oh no he's going to
ask me he's on the phone of course yeah
i sent her an email i sent her an email
so i don't have to hear her roll her
eyes
over the phone how do you get deniro do
you know him personally i did you know i
worked with him saturday live like six
years ago and we had fun he's a really
cool guy he's like okay when you worked
with him on saturday night live did it
was it so much fun that he said to you
uh uh jimmy i want you to take my home
phone number and you have it and call me
from time to time when we're gonna talk
that close a relationship even running
into him it's just like
right and then he walks away the door is
closed
i'm stuck in a room with jug dash and
all the guys from animal house so how
does this come about you you you you had
to call him personally right you know i
had uh yeah i i actually i used lauren a
little bit too i'm like come on can we
call uh jane rosenthal which is uh de
niro's partner right i'm like can you
ask uh if robert de niro would come on
and uh they said yeah he'd love to he'd
be honored
right off the bat and he's got nothing
to plug and i was like that's cool and
we did this bit it was silly but we did
like a fake movie that we were in that
never got released but what we did was
if you're in the studio we did it live
right in front of a screen like a green
screen like a saturday night live sketch
exactly right so the audience loved it
probably people at home didn't
understand what it was all about yeah
that's good so 200 people enjoyed it
2.4 million people